the Joe Rogan experience speaking of
what you see Vitor getting ready for one
Fc get something it's throwing fast
combinations looking juicy juicy ah I
love that big again what weight is he
fighting at is he fighting at 205 205
right this is a boy how many more years
do you think he can have under those
loser guidelines I think does it for
three more you they won't even let you
saw it in the country to watch now you
can't get out now okay but if we don't
even do it out I'll get that we don't
have anything to do it out out out
that's right he's won championship huh
yeah dude I mean of course he is come on
son just has that damn wife they're
helping them oh yeah why wouldn't ya
don't piss take my piss you take my this
stuff's perfect I'm eating Whole Foods
going to yoga class yeah they're killing
it sage is gonna fight again
- he's gonna drop down to 55 so here he
is get ready oh yeah dude I mean he's
and he doesn't have to cut weight so
that's where it gets interesting because
you know you got to realize that Vitor
has been fighting in the UFC at 185
pounds for you know all the big fights
right to fight with Anderson that he
lost and then the Anderson fight you
know he was a little smooth in that
fight it didn't look like the Vitor that
fought Rockhold or the Vitor that fought
Michael Bisping or Henderson that was
the thick Vitor so is that we're dealing
with a different animal what poor souls
gonna fight feet tall in the juice
hey man isn't enough at this age you
know is it enough you know I mean
they've got some straight-up murderers
over in one Fc
they do they do that [ __ ] guy who
knocked out Eddie Alvarez what's his
name
sorry You c'n sorry you can how about
the guy would be Brandon Vera man like
they have seen killers oh sorry Yuki
name oh nasty yuqian that's his name I
think it's Timothy nasty yukkin this
[ __ ] Russian savage city mouse bend
over there
yeah but also UFC you know not to throw
been asking on the bus but UFC went one
championship that's your best come on
over yeah but I think I think they did
at the I think it paid off for the UFC
cuz you wouldn't have Mazel Dolls
superstardom without what happened Ben
Askren yeah I think Ben you know it
worked for both one champion UFC it
worked out if yeah for sure and it
worked for Ben too because he made a lot
of money one percent when FC but I think
if Ben had left Bellator and concentrate
to the UFC things would have been very
interesting very hard the paint for Ben
hmm got starched hey get started there's
a tough girl
start standing strangled hey it's a
tough world out there and you know we
found out also that he needs a [ __ ]
hip replacement yeah a legitimately does
I'm connecting him with doctor Reardon
oh good I love Panama I love Ben but
also you know people dog himself is like
dude what about what about the guy who
was retired had everything going for him
where he's living as the wrestling camp
was like yeah alright I'll fight the
best the best in UFC like dude right
away just for him to do that you have
tip your hat to the guy it's [ __ ]
insane and super nice guy very smart guy
to really well all the [ __ ] talk that's
all an act
I think it's Ben's a great dude smart
smart guy wasn't the best idea to do
that to Mon spit although what you say
talking [ __ ] tomorrow at all
well well heat but that's that's his
game like he's not gonna tune into just
a pure wrestler yeah dude but there's
some guys oh well like what dude how
about Maz Badal I'm sorry how about been
askin verse Demian Maia
the strike and I was like what the [ __ ]
is happening right now ya know to the
ground you to right now yeah what is
this I'd rather watch Logan Paul ksi why
is this happening well you got to
remember Demian Maia beat monster doll
that one of the last fights that moms
were all lost was but decision Maya know
he I thought he'd be glad no no beat
Damon mind I don't think Damien had his
back remember and they restarted I think
Demian Maia one that decision I'm pretty
sure Jamie lost a wonderboy Thompson and
I think he lost Adele he beat Demian
Maia did he he right think
yes no no no no Mazel Mazel Tov no no
Maggie Amazo dog Demian Maia
I thought lose my try to turn him
remember I thought my wife she might
want a decision yeah Jamie my one yeah
shout out to your brain and I remember
he lost a really close one to wonder boy
really close but what's it what's
interesting about the the Mazel all
Demian Maia fight is rare my had his
back and couldn't submit him true which
is insane
well you know where my I got [ __ ] more
than any other time in his entire career
is when he had Camaro whose Montespan I
was ridiculous
oh so ugly this day to that this day
I'll be driving to my [ __ ] car
Hori Maz Woodall said day me my loss
burns like a [ __ ] STD hilarious
sometimes I'll be driving no [ __ ]
I'll be driving down the road and I
think it Demian Maia having Camaro boost
Mons back and the referee stepping in I
go like this [ __ ]
just drive instead of know if someone
saw me driving they would think that I
have some personal thing I'm dealing
with or money I'm just driving down the
road thinking about that ref pulling
Demian Maia off Iceman's back and I just
go [ __ ] that was insane it was so Dom
insane it's like he yeah he got to the
spot that's the spot next thing you know
who knows what happened he's at the spot
but it's his spot it's his he's the best
in the world on your back the best and
it's early we're in the first round
he's not even slippery yet you called
the the Demian Maia ask him fight to a
tee I knew that was Ted before like no
no Dave Maass gonna strangle Timmy
Amaya's world class on the ground and
Ben eventually wants to go to the ground
what do you want to do I have a
kickboxing fight there's gonna be
moments where he wants to go to the
ground okay now if you look at what and
this is obviously different cuz it's
just MMA I mean it's just grappling not
MMA but he rolled with marcelo garcia
and if you watch marcelo garcia strangle
Ben Askren over and over and over again
you realize there's levels to everything
if they were just in a wrestling match
ya been askin could probably beat him
but this is not a wrestling match this
is MMA with strangles and Damien mines
gonna get his back that's what I was
thinking I was like he's gonna get his
back but also it is pretty similar to
straight jiu-jitsu because Ben
or Damien aren't really not in ours yeah
they're not ground-pounding there's
literally vying for position to grapple
so bends can entertain the grappling
with Damien - he's gonna slip up he's
gonna slip up and that's what I felt
like he wasn't gonna be able to as
Hickson Gracie would say couldn't keep
the rhythm
dude hop the transitions where are you -
foaming up them I could not get nothing
when they were staying like YouTube
[ __ ] drop down right now
yeah stop it god damn it the only thing
that made sense to me is maybe Demian
Maia thought that Ben Haskins chin would
be soft because he was so brutally kod
just four months ago maybe because that
has happened to go yeah right you
remember when Travis looter clearly
[ __ ] knock out cold with one punch
that same due to Vitor Belfort cut a
giant hole above his head he was a super
jacked really powerful black dude
goddamn it I can't remember his name
pull up Travis looter not even Marvin
Eastman exactly Oh
Marvin Eastman fought Travis looter and
Travis looter caught Marvin Eastman with
a punch at the very end of the punch it
was one of the weirder knockouts that
you'll ever see go back right here right
here right now watch this
oh very end of the punch very end of the
punch it was strange
but Marvin Eastman had been ko'd the
word was you got killed twice in camp
with Tito Oh got hit with an e during I
like takedown defense got K out and he
got hit with something else that was the
word I don't know if that's true if it's
wrong forgive me but it's not the Travis
looter couldn't punch he certainly could
but that one didn't make sense no not
like he touched him and he just went out
so sometimes guys who've been ko'd
recently you know it is they just can't
it just doesn't work anymore you know
and I would maybe I think Damian ma
maybe thought that Ben Askren took
couldn't take a shot
[Applause]